are you hearing me well yes i am hearing
me
so now first of all i want to advertise
again for
those of you who didn't hear about it
focm conference will be
will
maybe
will yeah it will be and so that's uh
actually that that is the focm society
website so that's the way i go to the
focm conference website this year so i'm
glad to see there is a very
big part of the focm crowd here and mike
was one of the founders of the society
so
and so if you go to the website of the
conference it will be take place in
montevideo
in december december 11 to 20 and it's
really a nice conference for those of
you who know many people here are going
to speak there there are like three or
four workshops that are really linked to
this
program so one is the computational
algebraic geometry workshop
which is organized by agnes and by
carlos andrea and by greg
smith thank you another one is the real
complexity real number complexity
workshop organized by felipe and by
shogata and ecalo beltran
and there is another one on continuous
optimization i think the cynthia is
speaking there and there are many
workshops related to the people here so
maybe when you see the list of
participants
those of you who haven't
registered yet want to go
so look that's very that's
a former student of mine santiago
appliance made this and this is
extraordinary so you have all the
participants by day get tempted and go
to focm
and then also we also have all the
abstracts of talks and posters up to
date
so for instance if you go there you will
see the abstracts of the plenary talks
the conference is starting with andres
meredi he's giving the first talk and
mike is giving the second dog in the
first day so if for instance if you
click here you have all the abstracts
and you can see
okay so this is the advertisement of the
conference
please come
so now
i'm going to start my talk
um
okay good
thank you very much first yes thank you
okay
first i'd like to
thank the organizers for having me
speaking here it's a great pleasure
and i will speak on a subject which
might be a little bit further than the
ones we
heard about on these days except it's a
little bit related the second part of
the talk will be a little bit related
with with naresh talk because it will
treat about things on finite fields
polynomials and finite fields but i will
start with the
new challengers
so let me remind what the north stalin
state is about
inbert
nunchtel and sat
that's the german word
for the
theorem of the
place of zeros
and that's
more mo gilbert
more or less in 1883
and in a very
indian in its weak form what it says it
says is that if you have polynomials f1
fs
in a
polynomial ring
over a field and for an ins a moment
let's assume that the field is
algebraically closed
and if these polynomials do not share
any roots
in the
algebraic so if these polynomials do not
share
any root
well
so the variety they define is empty
this is exactly the same than saying
then you can write one as a polynomial
combination of f1fs that is what the
nullchallenge says so written in an
ideal
way it would say this
but if we if we write the coefficients
it would say that there exist polynomial
g one with gs in k of x1 xn
such that you can write one as g1 f1
plus gsf s so this is a
very important theorem in algebraic
geometry
and
what we can observe first is that it
translates a geometrical problem
the problem of having or no solutions to
an algebraic
question of writing one as a polynomial
combination of some given polynomials
but as it is it is not constructive
so if you do not do
if you do not know anything else you
cannot really solve the problem the in
this way
but
even if it's not constructive in this
way what it says
is
if there are some polynomials j1 gs
then
if there exists they will have some
degree
so you can
knowing that they will have some degree
that exists and let's call the degree
the degrees of the f i's in all my talk
will be d i
and they'll always be bounded by a d
and let's assume that if this gi exists
they have a certain degree bounded by
capital d
which means that
if you have a capital d you can state
every polynomial gi as a polynomial
of the grid d in the x1 xn variables
with unknown coefficients
and then when you write these
expressions what you observe
is that you will marry the coefficients
unknown coefficients of the gi's with
the known coefficients of the fis
and so that will give you for each
monomial in this expression that will
you that will give you
a linear form
with unknown coefficients of gi's known
coefficients of fis so you will end up
solving this problem solving a linear
system of equations
comparing the exponent by exponents so
the only exponent which is not the only
coefficient which is not zero here is a
constant coefficient
so what does that mean first observation
that means that if you start with
polynomials
for instance for instance with
coefficients with rational coefficients
in q and you solve your linear system of
equations you will never leave the
rational field q solving linear systems
of equations you don't you know you do
not leave the field which means that
here
we do not need to assume that k is
algebraically closed but what what we
are looking for are solutions in the
algebraic closure of k but these
polynomials g
g o g one g s will be will have
coefficients in the base field k
okay moreover
same reasoning if you start with an in
a domain a
with quotient field
k
and if you start with polynomials
f1 fs
in a
so what we you will end up with
polynomials g one g s in k of x one
k
x kx1 xn but this polynomial g1 gs will
have a common denominator and this
command denominator will be a nonzero
number in a
so which means that you will end up
having polynomials in a and an alpha in
a
minus 0
such that alpha can be written as a
polynomial of thank you
very kindly
such that alpha can be written as a
polynomial combinations of of
combination of f1fs so
now everything is in a of x1 xn
the fi's the gi's and this alpha is a
number if non-zero number in a
so okay so we decided that
only observing that this
means
to solve a linear system of equations
means that now we have a domain and we
have things in the quotient field of the
domain
and another thing is that now
imagine what is effect people speak
about effective knowledge talent sets
what is
effectiveness it is
given polynomials f1 fs with certain
degrees
give an a priori bound for the
polynomials gis
the rebound for the polynomial gi so
find such a d
which will realize this bezel identity
that is usually called bezu identity so
which realizes it realizes bezuar
identity so why is that because once you
have your d
imagine that you have your d
and you want to solve this question as a
linear system of equations what do you
have you write that how many unknowns do
you have
the unknowns
are the number of coefficients of all
polynomials gis
so you have s polynomials gi's
and each polynomial is of degree big d
capital d in n variables
and as
was explained yesterday in the first
talk the number of coefficients of a
polynomial of the grid d in n variables
is this combinatorial number
so this is more or less something like s
d to the n let's say
of this order that's a number of
unknowns
and the number of equations
corresponds
to the number of
coefficients you have in this expression
so this expression has degree d plus
capital d and variables
and in variables that's that is the
number of coefficients you will have to
look for
and this is more or less something like
d
small d plus big d
to the n
so that is the size of the linear system
of equations you will have to
to solve so why do i say this because i
said effective initial assets is
bounding the degree
what is arithmetic knowledge challenge
my the subject of my talk today
arithmetic nusselt and sex is if you
start with a domain with a notion of
height for instance if you start with a
equal the integer numbers
you can imagine that a height of a
polynomial is the log of the max of the
absolute value of the coefficients
that's a height of a polynomial so
height of a polynomial f
in z of x 1 x n
is the log
of the max
of the coefficients
that is
an example of a domain with a height
notion
so height of a number is the log of the
number is what why is it that is
because it's the number of bits you need
to write the number in a computer
essentially
and another example of a domain
is take this is a equals z
take a equal
a function field
in a function ring sorry in any numbers
of variables you want
so that's why i
put t with a bar any number of variables
you want so that's
and here in this case
the notion of height is simply of a
polynomial f
in k of t of x 1 x n is simply the
degree
in t of the polynomial f
so that that will be the notion of
height of a polynomial in this case
so
this is in the case f in key
of k of t of x 1 x n
and this is the case
f in z of x 1 x n okay these are the two
notions of
two domains that we work with and the
two notions of heights i will use
and uh
i am introducing heights for what
imagine that you started with g one g f1
fs in a of x1 xn with the notion of
height you can you may wonder too is
okay if i have a bezel identity what is
the bound for the degrees effectiveness
challenge sets and what is the bound for
the height
what is the bound for this alpha which
is a
integer number or a
polynomial in k of t of t and what is a
bound for the height of these
polynomials so that is arithmetic motion
and sense okay is effective plus the
height bound
clear the problem is clear yeah
so
first observation
this is the problem
so first observation
once you have a degree bound
once you have the degree bound you
immediately inherit a height bound
why is that because you have this linear
system of equations that you can solve
so if you use cramer's rule you have
this big matrix
that you need to solve and this matrix
the coefficients of this matrix will be
the the coefficients of the polynomials
of i's so imagine they all have heights
h
small h because it's a logarithm
yeah there was one reason why i didn't
want to
oh
well you probably are trying to avoid in
the center because you're going to pull
the center apart but if you've written
first in the standard then you could
i i was trying to do that and i forgot
when i started
yeah no it's
so very very
good
i can go here
so here is your big matrix that you have
to solve here are your announced here
zero zero one or 0 0 1. so you use
kramer's rule the size here of
everything is h the height of every
polynomial is h
coefficients so what do you have at the
end no it's big h let me not take
logarithm yet take really the degree of
the polynomials or the coefficients of
the f so at the end what do you have
here essentially you will you will have
h to the d
when you take that by camera's rule you
take the determinant of this and the
denominator is also a determinant here
so the size will be h to the d if you
take the log
that will be d
yeah and what is the size of the matrix
thank you yeah because if not it would
be very simple
you're right thank you
so it is
h to the s d
to r let's say d to the n to simplify
like this so if you take the log of this
d to the n
log h
so if you started with polynomials with
whose coefficients
uh
have height log of h
then you end up with this
so what happens
um
the first bounds the first general
bounds for this problem were given by
grete hermann
in 23 1923 and what she found is a bound
of type
d equals
small d degrees of the f i's to the 2 to
the n more or less essentially so a
bound which is doubly exponential in the
number of variables
so this was greater harmon
but then
there is
this example which appeared
and which is the worst example
that
anyone could ever find
now i would like
when you want to project your equations
they could go on the sideboards you
could just right here
she she doesn't have to you know you're
going to project a slide or two i only i
need to keep the example i'm writing
before the slide what i mean is she
could put the slide up there and then
you can just write wherever you want
okay would you prefer that
if so she'll do it okay
thank you
all right so let me give you an example
the example is a very famous example is
due to braunabil philippe massa a lot of
people in the 80s 86 more or less
and it's a very nice example
so it's a system of n polynomials
in n variables
very simple f1 is equal to x1 to the d
f2
equals x1
xn
to the d minus 1 minus x2 to the d
f n minus 1
equals x n minus 2
x n to the d minus 1
minus x n minus 1 to the d and then the
last polynomial and this example example
i will give it in the parametric case
so it's a polynomial with coefficients
in k of t
minus x n minus 1 x n to the d minus 1.
so if you look at these polynomials
these are n polynomials in n variables
so variables are the x
this is the it's in k of t
and it has degree every polynomial has
agree exactly d
and it's very easy to see that these
polynomials do not share any common root
in the algebraic closure of k of t
no because if x one is equal to 0 then
x2 needs to be equal to 0 and you go on
and you go on and you have that x and
minus 1 is equals to 0. and then you you
have that t
to the h is equal to 0.
but find the coefficient
there so which means that there are no
common zeros so you i will be able to
write
a polynomial alpha and t
as a polynomial expression of f 1 f n
which means that alpha
is equal to this
and this is a very
common trick
what one does is i will specialize this
identity
in values
that
make
every polynomial vanish
from the last one
backwards to the second one because i
cannot make all the polynomials vanish
of course
so what do i do i choose x n to be 1
over a variable u
so if x n is 1 or 1 over y let's say
and then i
fill it
i choose x n minus 1 in such a way that
this vanishes
so the right choice is
since i won't be able to do it now
nobody can verify this if you take x
minus 1 to be t to the h y to the t
minus 1
this
dies
and then i i
replace x n minus 1 by this value x and
by this value and who is x n minus 2 and
i will write it for you
t to the d h
y to the d square minus no i did one
yeah the square minus one
and two to two we continue like that
backwards
and then at the end x one
is t to the d to the n minus two
times h
y to the d to the n minus 1 minus 1 and
this is what i called
y
y thank you
so what happens now when i replace in
this expression i specialize this
expression in this underlying y y
so everything dies except the first one
so and we will have this alpha which is
a polynomial in t
which be
equal to g1 which depends on t and x
times f1
specialized here
but f1 specialized here is simply
the first coordinate to the d
so this gives t to the d to the n minus
1 times h
y to the d to the n minus d
very interesting
now
and this is of course this is um
an expression which depends on t and h
it's all polynomial except for this term
so if if one looks at this very
violently
one
say okay something in t needs to be this
and here i have this y to the d n minus
d how can i get that
and the the only way you can get that is
that the degree in
x n of this g y has to be very big
this is good for every value of y it has
to be very big it has to to kill this
part so this means
that if you look at this the degree
in xn of g1
g1
has to be greater than the n minus d
and also if you replace y by one
this means that
this
t to d
if you replace y by one everything is
polynomial
there there is no more rational
expression here and this means that
the degree
of alpha as a polynomial in t has to be
greater than d n minus 1 times h
so this is the conclusion so let me
summarize these in
understand why is the degree in alpha
d
so put here y equals one
so if you put y equal to one this is an
expression in t a polynomial in t
polynomial in t times polynomial in t
that needs to be a polynomial and t
so this degree divides this degree
or divides it's lesser
this polynomial divides this polynomial
so the degree
okay so i will summarize this that as
the max
of the degree of g1 f1
remembering that the degree of g of f1
is d this gives this
and the height
the height of alpha
is greater than d minus n minus 1 times
h
so this is a lower bound for the problem
if we want a general solution we will
get
at least this bounce
we are looking for upper bounds we will
get at least this bounce
is it clear what i'm saying
so this is when i want to show the
example
something happened
nothing ah because this
computer sleeps yeah so how do i thank
you
come on
let me skip the
let me skip it because so what i wanted
to show is that there is
effectively an example which realizes
the bazoo the bazoo identity with
exactly this
now this is because my computer is very
slow and it's so different
okay
so about
first effective nuclean cells so about
effectiveness challenges there is a big
gap between these doubles doubly
exponential bound by grete hermann and
the known lower bound so there were a
lot of people working on that and there
were a lot of work
in the 86 87
so the
series of papers and the best bound was
on 87 by collar
and it was
of type
d to the n
model of some detail
but then
in
jalonek came out with a very beautiful
with a very beautiful geometric proof
of the same fact
where he actually he improves colors
bound so
can you log into your computer
thank you this is
is it here too yeah it's it's on the
side if you want to put it in the center
here wait here
protect it open it up
i'll turn this on
oops okay now let's let's let's use that
it's warming up
this multimedia thing is not
okay i will show it here
look
this is the solution can everybody see
here or
kind of strange but here my polynomial
is the one i gave at the beginning
and if you look here this is the
expression t to the d n minus 1 times h
equals a polynomial combination
and if for instance here is the last
polynomial is hidden here inside the fn
the fn is hidden here the fn was t2 the
h minus xn minus 1xn to the d minus 1.
it's hidden here and then the fn minus 1
is hidden here
the f 2 is here then here and f 1 is
hidden here
so here you have a polynomial
combination and if you if you look every
term cancels the only term that survives
is this one which is equals to this so
this is exactly a bezel identity with
the stated
with the stated bounds that were written
here and now disappeared
here
with the exact bounce
so what i want mom
so
unplug the laptop
okay i won't show the sec i have a
second slide but i don't do it
i don't show it because this will be
terrible
this will be
i'm sorry i'm sorry for this well this
will be terrible so anyway
i i told you
that if you have a degree bound you have
a height bound
but our degree the best degree is d to
the n
so
this would give a height bound of type d
to the
no what is my height bound
right there
here
okay
so this would be a bound of type d
n square
log h
so that is what cramer's rule gives as a
height bound using the best degree bound
and that's that this is
the best
the lower lower bound people know so if
you can compare there is a really a gap
between the exponents n minus 1 here and
the n square here there is an
exponential gap
so arithmetic null challenge sets dealt
with putting
bounds for the side for the heights so
there was also a lot of work on that the
first uh working on that is was
philippon who gave a bound for the
denominator for the the height of alpha
only in the case e equals z
so philippo and then also
and
bernstein
this way bernstein
and i would like to report here on a
result with carlos andrea and martin
sombra
which is the following one
i'll treat the cases e equals z
and e equal k of t
the parametric case and
a was the
the domain there
okay
so you start with polynomials f1
fs on a of x1 xn with which do not share
any common root in the algebraic closure
of the quotient field of these domains
so you end up
with an alpha
in a minus 0
and of g1 gs
in
a of
x1 xn
such that
so
this result is for s
my uh bounded by n plus one polynomials
it's an exact result for s for less than
n plus one polynomials
the result is that the degrees
in export of g y f i are bounded by the
products of the polynomials
and the height
of alpha
which in the case
here k of t means the green t of alpha
and in the case z
means
the log of
the absolute value of alpha
and the height of the gi's
plus the heights of the f i
are bounded by an expression
which is very
precise
it depends
exactly on the degree of each polynomial
and on the height of each polynomial
here is
for
j different from l so it's a sum
of this type and this is the bound in
the case
k of t
and in the case z
there is a correction term
which is
of type o of
n log n
times the products of the degrees
so this is
the result we got in in this situation
and i would like to so i will make a
couple of comments on this result but
first i would i would like to
look again at our example that we had
here
d sub j h sub l
so that is the height of each of the
polynomials
okay
so
let's look at this example in this case
so in this example we have n polynomials
we're in the good situation and
polynomials and all the polynomials have
the grid d
but
look at the heights the only polynomial
which has a height which is not zero is
this one
which which has high height h
so which means that in in this
expression there is only one term which
survives
it's the term when you chose
n equal n
so you get
d to the n minus 1 times h
so this is the height bound you obtain
when applying this result to this set of
polynomials
and the degree bound of course is the
product of the degrees which is what we
got there so in this case it's an exact
match
so this bound match is exactly the
the lower bound in this case
in not in the integer case in integer
case we have this correction term the
reason why there is a big difference not
a big difference this difference between
the two cases
is mostly because when you look at the
height of a polynomial in the parametric
case
the height of a product is the sum of
the heights
but when you look in the integer case
if you took take two polynomials with
coefficients in z and you take the
product
the height of the product is not the sum
of the heights there is a term because
you have to add a lot of terms there is
a correction term
so the fact that you have to add this
lot of terms is the fact that gives you
this correction term here so that's the
difference between the two cases and i
don't know if that will
be solved
at some point
another interesting example
that i will give before switching to the
second part
is the example of the resultant
of
polynomials
so
one
we can obtain the same result but
instead of working
with one
group of variables we can
work with several group of variables and
get
precise results for each group of
variables so imagine you have
polynomials
f 0
to f n plus 1
to f n excuse me generic polynomials of
degree d i's
generic meaning that you take
unknown coefficients variable
coefficients so t
alpha x to the alpha in n variables
t
zero alpha
t n alpha
x to the alpha and here of the green
d
n this one of the v d zero
so and you take the resultant of this so
the resultant of this family of
polynomials
is
as you know a polynomial in the
coefficients
which
belongs to the ideal so which can be
written as a polynomial combination
and it's known that the degree in each
group of variables ti of the resultant
is
the product
of the other
product
to for g different from i
d
j
that is the degree in each group of
variables of the resultant so when you
apply
also when you apply this result to this
situation you obtain exactly that
so
really
the polling the polynomial alpha you
obtain applying this result
is a multiple scalar multiple of the
resultant
so
this bound
is not tight for the x but it it is
tight for the degrees in teeth so that
is
essentially the first part of my
of the talk
but i would like to report on
how this um
nurselandsat
is being used as an ingredient
in proofs
for problems on finite fields so somehow
there is a switch between structures
and for this
what is used actually is not the these
knowledge talent sets but the strong
nurse telling sets
which is
i think that everybody knows that but
if you have a poly f1 fs polynomials
and an f
which doesn't vanish on the
on the common roots of f1fs
so f
doesn't vanish
on the common so what you know is that
there is a
alpha in a
a power mu
in
n
such that alpha
f to the mu
belongs to the ideal f1 fs
so
if f doesn't belong to the what is the
condition that i
am v of f1fs
yes i'm confused that's vanish of course
yeah yeah
excuse me yeah
so um
everybody knows that the strong news
challenge that is a consequence of the
weaknesses and sets by the famous rabbin
of its trick
and a slight modification of this trick
allows also to give bounds for this
alpha for this mu and for this
j's in these conditions so actually
this is what is being used
for the the things i saw over finite
fields
mostly a size for the denominator and in
the case z
so there are like
two problems that i want to
to mention
and i will speak only on one of them
so the first one is from a paper by
bombing
of 2009
and
what i found interesting is the switch
of structures the fact that they can
solve a problem on finite fields
switching to
to c
to the
characteristic zero but not to a
rational parameter c
so
this is about
i call it a witness theorem
but it's not it is not a witness in the
sense that we heard today
it's a weakness in the sense of smell
so i will explain it
so you fix n
you fix d
and then there exists a constant
which depends on an nd
a small one
and two big constants
it depends on n and d
such that for any prime p
prime number p and any group
multiplicative group in the finite field
fb
multiplicative
at least one of the three following
things
happens
one of the three
one
e is small
in some sense
the prime is small which means p is
bounded by a
third the c two which depends on nd
second
the group is small
b small or the group is small
which means that it really has a small
projection in one dimension
so
the group has a small projection
there exists
alpha different from beta
exponents
with
alpha beta bounded by d this will be
exponents
such that the projection in one
dimension
of the group
the size of the projection it is bounded
by this constant c one
i'm sorry you said for all p and then
you say p small no no one of the three
things happens for all p either p is
small or if p is big we will have one of
these conditions
so
and let me write it
projection in one variable
if you have a gamma here which is a
gamma one gamma n you project to gamma
to the alpha minus beta
that's gamma to the alpha divided by
gamma to the beta
thank you we all know what you mean
so
either p small either the group is small
or either
that is the witness part
there exists a point in the group
which is a weakness
for all polynomials of the grid d
and height and small height
which is a weakness for all polynomials
of small degree and weakness
with-ness
for all polynomials of
non-zero
of degree
bounded by d
and height
bounded by
epsilon
excuse me
e to the epsilon
and here by height i mean the absolute
height not the logarithmic height what
what does that mean that if i take any
polynomial f
in z of x 1 f of x 1 x n which is
non-zero
of degree bounded by d
and of
height absolute height non logarithmic
height
bounded by
p to this
epsilon
then
f in this gamma is different from zero
so there is a gamma
in the group
which is a witness for all polynomials
of small degree and small height that's
the witness theorem in the sense of
spain
so and what is um interesting is
i'm i'm not going to comment on the
proof of this result i'm going to
comment one minute in the proof of the
second result i want to mention
but in the case of one variable it's
simply it's a very simple ideal idea
what do what they say is if this doesn't
happen
then it won't happen for a gamma and
gamma square
for instance gamma gamma square which
means that there will be a polynomial
for gamma which vanishes on gamma of
small degree and height and there will
be a polynomial for gamma square which
vanishes on gamma square
so if you have the polynomial f1 which
vanishes on gamma and f2 which vanishes
on gamma square
the polynomial f1
and the polynomial f2 to the x square
have a common root
so the resultant vanishes
was p
not p because you are about p
the resultant vanishes
but which means that the resultant when
you look at it in z
is divisible by p
so if the resultant is non-zero this
gives a bound for p
because it's bounded by the resultant
and if
the resultant in z is zero for any
choice of gamma and gamma square
then you will end up
you will end up
showing somehow that your polynomials
are
cycle atomic polynomials and etcetera
etcetera etcetera but the reasoning is
very neat so they they they
look at the polynomial
which vanishes mod p but they look at it
in the integers so the polynomial has
two possibilities is it it is zero and
if it's not 0 it's divisible by p so
that is how it works so the second
result which is
completely different
so okay
it has the same
so
what i said about the resultant is the
case of one variable if you want to go
to many variables you use the strong
null challenge that you find a
polynomial which has to be
in an ideal
and you have here a number which is zero
mod p and this gives
the conclusions you are looking for
the second result is a result on
size of
product sets
in fp
and this is
parlinski
2012.
so what they say is if you have s
different from t in fp
and they look at the
sets
that i denote a h
which is the set of
ratios
x plus s divided by x plus t
for x
between
1 and h
they look at this set
so this set has
h elements
if one looks at it
and
what they say is that there exists a
universal constant
c1
such that
for all
or all
are in them
there exists a constant which depends on
r only
satisfying that for all primes
p and h
such that there is this relation between
h and p
so h is small enough compared to pin
then
the size
of the products
of
our elements of a
h
so you multiply r elements of this form
and you look how many elements you
obtain
at the end doing this multiplication
so if you were looking at the the at the
product
you would have
h to the r elements but here you
multiply them and you can have repeated
elements so the size of this
is
philosophically what it should be as big
as it can be
so it's
exponential
of minus c r
log h
divided by log log h
times h to the r
so it's a
a multiple of the biggest possible size
and again so this is also a result it's
a result it's completely different than
this in its flavor
it's a result on finite fields but what
they do again is that they translate
this result to result in c
and how do they do that they they look
at the map
which sends
an element x
in
the interval 1 h
so they look at the interval 1 h
to the r
and they send it to the products
x plus x 1 plus s x 1 plus t
times
x
r plus s
x r plus t
x1 xr
here
and there
so they look at this map
this map
in fb
but then they look okay when do
two images here will be the same so if i
look at two
elements here that have the same images
that will give a polynomial relationship
because the numerator of the first one
times the denominator the second one has
to be the numerator or second one times
the denominator of the first one so this
gives a
polynomial relationship so this
polynomial relationship
i will show i will create an ideal with
all the possible polynomial relationship
of that type
and i will
translate this ideal which is in fact
over fp i will look it in z of
in the characteristic zero case and i
will show that this ideal
has
something that is out of the diagonal in
it
and so that is the way that they use to
translate it's always the same thing
they switch a problem on finite fields
they switch it to c
and in c it's easier to solve complex
um
algebraic geometry is easier than in the
finite field case so they go to c they
solve it in c and then they come back so
and there is a third example i'm not
going to to speak about
there is a third example which a
different completely different flavor to
is finding
points of high
of high order
in varieties of a finite fields
so you have a curve on a fine defined of
a
curve defined over a finite field and
you want to find
how many points of high order it has
and also again there is
uh switching to the
the to the zero um
to the c case the complex case using
the strong muscle and sets at some point
creating an auxiliary polynomial
which belongs to a variety and then you
have such an identity but if this
identity holds since you have sizes for
this alpha you know that alpha
cannot vanish if p is sufficiently big
if p doesn't divide alpha this cannot
vanish so which means that this
polynomial will vanish and then blah
blah and the the argument follows so
i will end here
you mentioned at the very end you
mentioned the construction of auxiliary
polynomials
are these
is another application possibly that
fountain approximation like baker's
theorem like in baker's theorem there's
israeli polynomials would resultants
would these kind of stellar sounds help
it all there i have no idea but that
would be
actually actually a last comment that i
didn't say
is i was speaking about two cases z and
k of t the results on z so there were
previous results on z the results on k
of t are new
but the reason why i mentioned this is
because in all these results they only
work on
prime fields with pier prime
because
if you work in fp even if you don't have
any
notion of size you do have a notion of
size
elements in fp are bounded by p somehow
but if you work in the in the field f q
with q p to the n you doesn't have the
same the analogous notion of of of size
so the analogous notion of size
would be
looking
at the field f q as
a quotient field no ft divided by a
minimal polynomial and then you can
write your elements in sq as polynomials
of a certain degree
in t in a variable t so in that sense
that's a work that we are
trying to do with some of these people
the new challenge has
the parametric null challenge that could
be helpful
for generalizing this kind of results to
finite fields which are not
fp of the type fp so that's them
so
in your result uh
the main result you assume that the
number of polynomials is at most n plus
one
how is it just a technical assumption
because i would expect that if it's more
polynomial the
the everything is easier right and
actually it's
in the case of more than n plus one
polynomials you can reduce to
n plus one polynomials it's easy to
reduce to that case but you lose
the exact dependency on each height and
each degree which is bad in some cases
and the reason is
is is due to the proof but it's a
geometric proof so in the proof of these
null challenge sets well it's what
yellowneck did
the bezu identity comes from a
coefficient
of an implicit equation of a map
so the map will
depend on the fact that you have less
polynomials at the dimension of the
ambient space or n plus one well
so it's important in the proof indeed in
this proof
so actually it's not easier if you have
there is no
proof all the results and the nurse
elena said they there is a difference
between the cases
less than n polynomials and more than n
polynomials
any other questions
okay well let's thank teresa again